Bitto way let's Nick this episode and
this is not fit to work as I like
talking about the show this episode here
is the one where you got Aang trying to
trailer had at Earthbend and at the same
time you got Zuko trying to learn how to
master whitening him and his uncle have
hooked back together again
not like in a relationship well okay
technically they were away but you know
I mean so his uncle is teaching him how
to essentially been lightning for like
my parrot term I think before I call
electricity which sort of CAD not really
lightning you know uh so you got these
two learning sort of their opposites
which I like you know there's something
they obviously push a lot is that Aang
and Zuko live very parallel lives and
they learn similar things at the same
point and I like they even with that
they had to learn their opposites and
both have to learn the opposite of the
other you have anger in order to
Earthbend has to learn to face something
head-on to be aggressive to be to be
fearsome to have no fear essentially to
really stand up to something and he has
Yoko who has to learn inner peace he has
to learn calmness he has to learn taking
on his pride that there's a wonderful
what was the quote pride is not the
solution to shame it's the cause of that
great line um and so you have them both
trying to confront this and even have
Katara pre-much say look you're
essentially right now you're an
airbender and you're trying to master
these other elements but earth is the
natural opposite so this is going to be
the toughest for you and I enjoy that I
like that the elements have different
philosophies as well as techniques that
airbending is very much about peace and
tranquility and earthbending is very
much it is very fierce and and there's a
mighty force so I like that I thought
that that was a good setup
you get a little bit more of Zuko trying
to come to grips with his pass obviously
although you don't really see any
flashbacks you get a little bit of the
uncle um I'm assuming they're going to
go more to the hem later obviously but
that's about it for the flashbacks most
of it is just the technique and the
philosophy of the technique which is
good you know it's with some of this
like with learning the waterbending from
Katara you see or Cersei okay now this
is a technique this is that there wasn't
really anything it was more motions it
wasn't as much the mindset or the
philosophy of the technique so I like
their going more and more into that they
dealt a little bit with it when he was
trying to learn firebending but I like
they really dive much more into it with
this and I like the idea I think people
always think everything having to do
with uh either martial arts or uh
they're an Asian techniques and
philosophies and stuff it all has to
deal with inner peace and inner quiet
and a lot of times it does but there are
times where you have to use that brute
force you know you're trying to achieve
this inner peace to see everything to
see with your eyes unclouded but at some
point you're gonna have to confront the
harsher things there's gonna be hard
shooting throw at you and you have to be
able to thrown it back well in fact
that's actually more what the the
airbending is about the earthbending is
very much not taking it throwing back
it's actually fighting against a it's
stopping it it's be just as strong if
not stronger to defeat it so I like that
I like learning these sort of different
philosophies of this world that
obviously have major philosophies from
our world as well um I'm trying to think
that there wasn't I mean it's not that
there's nothing going on this episode I
just can't find a ton to talk about with
it I I know I sort of feel bad saying
that but it's it's the basic technique
and it works it's nice to take an
episode that dives more to the technique
I guess the one thing that I would say I
would like done a little different is at
the very end
Zuko goes well first of all I like that
the uncle teaches him how to do
whitening bending without actually
bending any lightning I like they says
oh no we're not doing that I'm hoping
you'll never have to do that so now he
has the technique and the hope is that
he would never have to do it I like that
I like that
the uncle's teaching him but he won't
actually put him through it necessarily
he has to just trust him that he's good
enough to do it but that's not enough
for Zuko he has to go and he has to
climb the mountain tries to get the
lightning himself and it looks like he's
really coming face to face with his
shame essentially and again with this
sort of Aang is talking about fighting
something head-on uh Zuko is doing
something very similar I would have
liked a little a little longer on top of
that mountain and it's it's effective it
works I think it could have been like a
major tear dropping scene which I'm not
saying that like nobody didn't shed a
tear in this I'm sure somebody did you
know but man if you added like just
another minute you know which is a long
time in you know kids cartoons I
understand that I'm not feel like oh
come on this was obvious no I
you gotta it's a compromise I totally
get that I just wish there's like maybe
one more minute on that mountain just
seeing him try to come to grips with it
or just yelling at the mountain or
letting it hit him uh I think it
probably been more effective but yeah it
was still affected it still worked uh
yeah I guess it's a knee I can't think
of too much else to say on this one it's
not by any means a bad episode it's a
good episode to have like I said we get
more the technique it's just not Wow
holy crap was that like really really
good so but it was these it was a decent
episode I can't find too much else to
say about it so um yeah probably a short
one here but hopefully I'll have more to
say on the next one so I'll see ya there
at the next one at there I don't know
what that means